welcome everybody to a very special
episode of the 420 blazin Angley podcast
there's nothing special about it and we
are not smoking and we don't smoke and
we don't encourage people to smoke
because that's an illusion it's an
illegal activity and can get you in lots
of trouble not just with the government
but with your parents today's episode is
sponsored by on it me undies hems and
seat geek this is um I'm super excited
announced this on Monday we've got ninja
the twitch megastar joining us leave
your questions on the subarray he's
coming in at 2 p.m. PST I believe on
Monday this Monday
I am freaking super pumped to meet and
talk with ninja and then also I just
want to say a very happy national walk
out day which coincides with 4/20 which
is a happy coincidence right let's go
hey let's go protest gun violence
I'm blazed how did they both fall in the
same day I don't know
also Hitler's birthday apparently so Wow
busy day Columbine happen today
oh wait yeah I was never clear was the
guy who did the dudes who did Columbine
did they choose Hitler's birthdays
specifically or was it a coin
can you guys research let's celebrate
the biggest mass murdering [ __ ] that
ever exists
let's celebrate his life here's our
favorite 4/20 video this was by one this
guy it makes great content I know if
he's still making videos on your
computer this guy's a great man he's got
some real classics oh yeah he was making
videos back back back back in the day
when we were just walking around
shirtless this guy was getting it here
enjoy this guy's it it's that time buy
on your computer
oh you're never gonna believe what there
you go this guy's great check out on
your computer man I hope he's doing well
I wish him the best and I thank him for
all the laughs and all the gaps and all
the goofs and all the I'm not gonna say
the G word to you but that my head it's
uh that video is so well timed with the
mom walking the mom walking in and then
imagine if both his watch and the
microwave because you know sometimes
it's one minute off ruins it did you
ever did you guys celebrate 4/20 in his
role at all mmm I didn't even know about
it I don't know maybe people do did you
even know people who smoked it all in
Israel yeah but not a lot but I think
everyone does smoke I just was like ELA
ghosts don't tell my parents that weed
exists he's like don't tell him it
exists we made that video about how we
used to be drug dealers she's like don't
show that to my parents they don't know
they don't know that weed exists oh that
one was yeah it was afraid of their
reaction and then my mom was just she
just didn't mention it I think maybe you
think she saw it but was just like I
don't even know how to address this yeah
it's funny when I was in college UC
Santa Cruz 4/20 was like the biggest day
of the year really it's so ridiculous in
a way like thinking back like everyone
would go out and there's this meadow
it's called the meadow and everybody
from the whole school from the whole
town will pour into this meadow there's
thousands of people and you would see
the most obscene [ __ ] you would see
people who would roll a massive joint
with like a pound of weed and there they
would have like ten different shoots and
like 20 people would be hitting it at
once the cops would show up and there
they would be like
I don't I don't know what to do about
this because it's like a couple like
five cops show up this was before it was
illegal I mean this was like ten years
ago now it was it was before it was
legal but it was like was the T not
murder okay we did it wasn't really a
something that mattered because it was
just eccentric has a reputation like
that glaze right
so the teachers participated there was
probably some but when you have
thousands of people out there and
they're there peacefully exist you're
not causing problem its heart like what
actually can you're gonna start you can
come out the riot gear and start like
you know clubbing people because they're
having a marijuana cigarette so the
police handled it right but like just
this whole notion of glorifying weed
somehow I don't understand it people
don't glorify other drugs
why does we get glorified it's weird
it's kind of like you're in the club or
you're not people think about weed is
like this miracle it's like a miracle
like God God gave us this plant and it
solves every problem I'm enlightened I'm
chill natural it's all natural just
grows up from the earth and also it's it
doesn't harm you that's what they say
it's a perfect beautiful dress I
actually I personally would say to
people out there who haven't tried it
who will probably one day try it I would
say be cautious of this drug because
I've been more [ __ ] up mentally as a
result of smoking weed than any other
drug I've taken and I've taken a lot of
drugs and I'm not encouraging anyone to
take drugs you know make decisions for
yourself but of all of them that I've
taken weed has been the one that's like
[ __ ] me up the most I've had like bad
trips on and just been like mentally in
outer space in a bad way yeah I I also
have trouble with it whenever I try it I
just get like so paranoid and not I
can't enjoy anything I just write weird
like but I think it really depends on
the person you know yeah I think I wish
that I enjoy like I see some people who
are like um
freaking loving it but I don't know if
it's real I don't know if it's real I
think it through you think it's real
yeah I feel like weed is something you
have to smoke for like a full decade
before you can be like I'm just at peace
now with this drug the freakin blast me
in outer space there's also studies this
turned to like the anti weed I'm not
trying to like pain you could I don't I
don't care
do whatever you want my parents smoked
everyone I know smokes yeah my parents
and all my siblings smoke on a daily
basis so I'm not I'm just saying I don't
know why it gets put up on a pedestal
like nobody goes and buys a bottle of
like whiskey and it's like yeah man this
is gonna cure all your problems dude
you're gonna forget about all your
troubles comes at a price
that's a drug all right out there what
about wine would they say that there's
like a wine that's a lush lushes what a
lush is someone who abuses wine no I
mean would you do think there's a wine
like Club where people like idolize wine
the people are interested in wine
alright cuz there's like wine collector
is right but it's more about February
Jefferson has like a wine room in their
house yeah but wine isn't a well
alcohols the drug yeah and people don't
I mean yeah but people don't fetishize
it in the same way as like weed I think
whatever this conversation sucks anyway
to everyone out there who is blaze have
a great time who's just paid taxes hey
on to another topic oh yeah they said
that the Columbine was a coincidence
isn't that strange it was a
coincidentally on Hitler's birthday from
the Guardian the fact that the attack
took place on Hitler's birthday was a
coincidence boys had decided on 19th of
April the anniversary of the botched
government siege at Waco Texas okay
something else at least they're
celebrating yeah
oh wait that's it it says that it had to
be pushed back 24-hour
oh so I should actually contain I should
finish reading just lots of cherries
stuff 74 76 people perishing in a fire
all the good stuff okay
who's paid taxes we did taxes man I love
paying taxes you know what I wish about
taxes I wish there was a receipt because
I paid we're paying now about is race it
in like a hundred PDF with a hundred
pages really of they tell you how you
make your money
yeah they spent the money and that for
you that you paid I think that I should
be entitled to know where my [ __ ]
money went is that this would be great
at this point we're paying about forty
five percent of our income they're
making almost as much as we are
what the hell what I want is a receipt I
want to say your money was used to buy
two missiles you know three sandwiches
for the president yeah the gardener's at
the White House I don't know but like
there should be a breakdown of like
welfare you know like infrastructure
military health care I want to know I
guess you can find online but I'd like
to know would it be cool if you could
vote for how your money's spent
yeah so you pay your taxes you say you
you give them whatever fifty thousand
dollars in a year and then you get to
choose off with your money like hey I
want to I want this to go to health care
I want this to go to infrastructure and
you can decide as a citizen how you want
the government to spend your money won't
that be a cool way of like actually
deciding what's important so this point
we're spending like 50 percent of our
money on military I mean what what gives
dude I don't even understand the whole
military and the war here because it's
so weird how it's like you and war but
knowing something here it's all over
there right yours because it will in
Israel you feel when you're a poor you
understand why right there
but I was thinking that it's too like
recently you I'm sure
one heard the government with UK and
France bombed cereal in retaliation for
them using chemical weapons and I was
thinking I'm sitting here trying to be
like how do I feel about this like it's
a good thing it's a bad thing
yeah but then the the honest-to-god
truth I think is like who [ __ ]
actually in this world that is so
complexed I'm sitting out here and like
my comfortable life out in Los Angeles
how could I ever actually know what what
actually is going on there
how can i ordinary citizen actually
understand what the hell is going on in
Syria and why we're bombing them and why
have we been in perpetual war for two
decades I don't understand that's so
weird the concept how can I know how can
I know you I feel like to understand you
would have to have privileged
information or at least spent dedicating
like a full time amount of of
researching this and trying to
understand it and going there and seeing
what it's like in Syria you know let's
see what's actually going on there who
the [ __ ] knows what they're like how can
I have an opinion about it
people get so passionate one way or the
other about like oh it's good oh it's
bad it's probably bad
anytime someone bombs anything it's
probably bad it's just especially when
it becomes like related to politics I
feel like no one knows anything except
what their side right said on the news
you know right yeah yeah it's crazy I
mean I think we all have to understood
the internet and all these back channels
and all these countries scheming and
everyone's got I'll tell you our
alternative motives I honestly don't
know what to think about it but the
thing was that I found interesting was
that Trump he was ran on this whole
thing of being like America first I
don't give a [ __ ] and he railed on Obama
when Obama got involved in Syria yeah
and he was railing on Obama about don't
get involved in Syria and so it was just
seemed I had a character that all of a
sudden he's dropped bombs because that
was like his whole identity was America
for
let's not let's not be the police of the
world let's let the world sort of sum up
I thought it was just interesting that
all of a sudden he's so I wonder what
did he see what did he learn that
changed his mind so significantly
because I know his base a lot of people
who supported him were really upset with
that decision from the bombs here and I
wonder was there something he learned or
saw that we don't have access to it was
like where he was like this is important
yeah who could know who can decide they
did bomb chemical from what I read
they'd only bombed chemical weapons
facilities and research centers
associated with the chem the production
of chemical weapons they didn't bomb
like schools or hospitals or anything
insane like that and apparently they
also called war Russia through
backchannels and warned them so they
could get their people out which is a
good idea but that was something that
you used to criticize - all right don't
don't give in it's easy you know what
they say the crown the crown lays heavy
on the head mm-hmm it's easy to sit in
the peanuts gallery and [ __ ] all over
this poor son of a [ __ ] in charge
being the president it's got to be one
of the worst jobs in the whole freaking
world mm-hmm
that isn't that is a job for a very
specific unusual type of person
especially someone can do it good Trump
love him or hate him he was the biggest
mudslinger ever another Lee's president
he's doing all this the same stuff that
Obama did I'm not saying that as a
criticism of him like now he's bombing
Syria and he was saying to Obama don't
give away your plans ahead of time but
he did both of those things and I just
makes me think that he probably learned
something there when he understood oh
this is the right way to do it and
there's probably just so many codes and
things you have to follow right that I
wanted stuff I wanted an how much
decision they actually have you know
mm-hmm that's another who knows what the
[ __ ] knows I'm just a guy not even a
political science major I read reddit
like let's just be real with how how
much we understand about what's going on
this world you reading already is more
than I do I don't even I don't even go
there
I think we first need to acknowledge
that we don't know anything because
there's nothing I found myself doing
this to so it's fine happens everyone
but there's nothing worse than somebody
who has an a basic understanding of
something who's just browsed that title
and then we'll go out and argue in favor
of that and I find myself doing that too
and sometimes I'll be like wait I don't
what am I talking about I don't know
anything we don't know anything you
can't that's natural I don't know yeah
you can't just walk on it well I don't
know anything so I can't say anything
about yeah yeah yeah I know but but that
whole drive to want to like defend your
team is being used against us mm-hmm and
now like the Democratic Party is suing
Donald Trump did you know that it just
happened I think today or yesterday the
Democrats are suing Donald Trump for for
working with Russia to undermine the
election or something I don't know but
it's like we've got everything so
divided you you almost forget that were
were neighbors we're living in the same
country but it's like all-out war I
don't know what I guess that's how it's
better that way for everybody it's like
I don't know what's better
well like the powers that be it's almost
better right that that we're so divided
in a way because you focus more on like
how much you hate them then about
actually solving any problems it makes
you easier to control this is just a
conspiracy I don't know but it's been
like this for so long and no one's made
any meaningful efforts to actually
reconcile and it's just two parties it's
not that complicated you got one like
our disagreements are not that great but
somehow everybody [ __ ] hates each
other got CNN and Fox News and they
[ __ ] hate each other it's nuts I
don't know
it's like bro we're all we're neighbors
we got it we're sharing like you know
the thing is like when you're in a hat
when you were growing up and you get in
a brutal fight with your sibling you
still sit at dinner table together and
have dinner and then the next day forget
about it but I don't know how deep the
actual hatred for each other is going I
don't know
if it is or if it's like after the next
election or maybe there's a president
everyone like someone forget about I
don't know I know how bad it is it's
hard to tell I don't know anything look
at me trying to get all [ __ ] serious
conversation I feel like we smoked weed
I'm so blazed that would be the wouldn't
that be the best twist ever
all right here's speaking of politics
and all this [ __ ] you guys want to
see some scary [ __ ] I I've been meaning
to watch this for a long long time and I
just haven't had the opportunity here on
the podcast because we have so many
guests lately but you guys probably saw
this this is just unbelievable
talk about a threat to democracy and
some real 1984 [ __ ] look at this Eastern
Michigan communities we are extremely
proud with the quality that was
journalism that CBS 4 News produces
plaguing our country the sharing of
biased and false news has become all too
common on social media more alarming
some media outlets publish the same fake
story so a little background there these
are all owned by a huge conglomerate
media conglomerate called Sinclair and
they started buying up tons of local
news organizations and they starting to
use them they give them these forced
memos that they have to read you have to
read this verbatim word for word and
it's just it's this unbelievable
propaganda like the people who are
watching these local news don't know
that there this memo is forced from
someone upstairs who owns it seems like
it's an anecdote by these people you
watch it it seems like that person is
just it doesn't sound like they were all
they would all be reading something that
was like why would they this is a very
personal collection with the local news
those are your people right and so and
and then even further they're talking
about like one-sided news that is
corrupting them
ah cracy all the meanwhile while having
hundreds of people read this document
it's like it's actual doublethink you
remember that concert from 1984 or you
can both contradict yourself and believe
it at the same time wildin being aware
its actual doublethink
you can't criticize people for one sided
news and propaganda when you're
disseminating this for hundreds of look
it's it's it's actual doublethink it's
scary it's this is horrifying watch this
this is state media this is like what
you'll see in China or Russia when the
when the government owns the median I
have to say whoever edited this together
incredible that is a feat of
unbelievable so well like it's perfect
not just that editing but like actually
finding yeah the divide of all these
morning shows that this must have taken
unimaginable work to accomplish this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy love watching all these
Talking Heads you don't even know what
they're talking about or give a [ __ ]
acting like they care this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this it's
like they're all just doing an audition
right right the the balls the
doublethink it's just actual double
thing to make someone say this is a this
is a danger to our democracy
while undermining it it's on real it's
super scary this [ __ ] scared the [ __ ]
out of me
extremely dangerous to her democracy
this is you get that yeah
she was good she made it sound like she
was saying it I believe that but the
that's what's so bad it's like if you're
just watching your local news you have
no reason to doubt these people and then
it's convincing because these are your
people you know all right let's take a
quick break we've got a ton of stuff
please don't go away tons of tons of
stuff huge I've got a one-pound joint
that me Neil are gonna smoke just the
two of us right after this commercial
break so don't go away guys we'll be
Rebecca thank you - on it for sponsoring
this episode the h3 podcast on is a
fitness lifestyle company dedicated to
being the best that they can be by
improving every aspect of health
performance and wellness a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away workout
equipment had no personality and was
kind of an eyesore we all remember that
treadmill and live room that became a
coat rack or mom's dumbbells that ended
up as a doorstop mom looking at you mom
that's changing right goddamn now thanks
to on it a fitness and lifestyle company
and the makers of the primal kettlebells
I was like what is wrong
I looked up primal kettlebells it's
these incredible kettlebells with like
guerrilla bases is really cool but
here's what's going on now ahna has
developed a new force and fitness
featuring equipment inspired by
characters in the Star Wars universe
this is kind of insane that they got the
license just Star Wars look at this so
here we've got the kettlebell of Darth
Vader okay this thing weighs 70 flippin
lbs you guys have never seen me lift
this much how do they pack how the [ __ ]
do they pack 70 pounds into this thing
man it's crazy
so this is awesome it's a
Vader kettlebell they also got a yoga
mat when Han Solo yeah I wanted to show
that can you bring that in real fast
yoga mat they've also got one of
stormtroopers in boba fett of different
weight so you can have the whole flippin
collections really cool han Solo yoga
mat and the frozen Carbonite of course
here past that and a death star slamball
start slamball dude you slammed this
[ __ ] I don't know if I can slam it here
oh that's pretty cool man so if you're
into fitness and Star Wars fine you're
loves for each of them I personally find
these products would be a total blast
make your body a little more Han so I'll
make your body a little more Han Solo
and a little less Jabba the Hutt you
know what I'm saying
get them these make the perfect addition
to any fans collection and any home gym
head - on it dot-com slash Star Wars and
use promo code HD for 10% off your order
that's oh and then I t.com slash Star
Wars promo code h3 thank you so much -
on it for supporting our show making
these cool ass products appreciate you
let me just thank you to me undies ah
man what more can you say about me and
these except for this I these are my
favorite underwear by far I have always
rocked me in these because it's the most
comfortable it's the most breathable
it's the softest it feels the best you
can go ahead and take that call it has
got to take a call but me and DS must go
on the me and these parties must go on
God just it cradles everything so nice
it's crazy like I'm just I'm telling you
just try it it's so good I was on
Twitter recently like somebody found a
picture of me not wearing the image like
oh they're betraying you me undies as I
only have only have 3 pairs so me Indies
was like we got to fix that and they
sent me like a ton of underwear and I
couldn't be happier
couldn't be happier this stuff's amazing
like oh oh it's just underwear just try
it just try it and you're gonna
understand that it's not just underwear
it's incredible these boxers I don't I
don't mess with briefs but try the
boxers in my opinion you will never
regret getting that pair they are using
micro modal in their underwear it's
sustainably sourced naturally soft fiber
that starts with beech wood trees and
ends with the most amazing fabric you've
ever experienced they have got 100%
satisfaction guarantee me undies
guarantees you will love their undies or
your money back just give it a shot
you're gonna want to keep it because
it's so incredible here's the deal
mandis has a great offer for our
listeners for any first-time purchases
when you purchase my enemy undies you
get 20% off and free shipping give me a
break
mandis is so sure you're gonna love
their underwear they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
the first pair you get a full refund
it's a no flippin goddamn brainer and
I'm pissed about it because why aren't
you getting in already get 20% off a
pair get 20% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
so to get 20% off free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed go to Mandy's
comm /hd that's me undies dot-com slash
h3 and what I want is you guys to send
me pictures I want to see it you're
gonna understand how flex won't
breathable these are I want to see your
Fupa cradle you know and and like I'm
not even maybe this isn't a good idea
when we're trying to have kids but it
doesn't feel that damaging alright
thanks guys
welcome back to the a free podcast
thanks for sticking around I love you
for that I love you for that
can I say something I want to say
something everybody to first of all
everyone who's been watching and [ __ ]
in with the podcast I just want to
actually express my deep felt gratitude
and appreciation we recently started
making h3 videos again and I hate
talking about it because I just I hate
complaining about it in general because
it's been talked to death but we pretty
much don't make any money on YouTube now
and the podcast is our primary source
income now thanks to our sponsors and
everyone who sports us on on Twitch and
so you guys have got us to the point
where we're stable enough that we can
actually enjoy making videos for fun and
so that we can have them so we can make
videos with you for you guys I'm with
you guys
and not worry about the fact that like
we're not actually making money from
doing it and so to everyone who
supported us here I just really want to
say a big big huge huge huge thank you
it honestly means a lot not and I really
appreciate it so damn you had that
queued up like I was thinking about that
today we've enjoyed making h3 videos
lately and a large part is from the
stability we get here that we can do
that the podcast has been like our
anchor or I don't know what to call it
yeah so anyway it means a lot you guys
thank you all for for hanging out and
actually for giving us the opportunity
to like learn how to do this because
this is like our 62nd or 63rd episode
and I and I've always heard from other
podcasters and I'm learning now that
it's true that you really don't know
what you're doing with podcasts until
like the hundredth episode I believe you
know our first episodes were so rough
right and like it's pretty challenging
logistically but also mentally like to
talk in front of the camera for an hour
love live and then learning how to
prepare there's a lot to and and just
knowing how to interact with people yeah
it's something that I've struggled with
and I sit down have a conversation with
somebody you're boring are you trying to
be too funny are you trying to be to
find you need to calm down now you feel
quiet it's like it's crazy thing and in
any way thank you guys for giving us the
audience and for giving us that the
chance in time to improve at it as well
I don't think we're good at it yet but
yeah we're trying guys we spoke
previously about laptop wars because
Milla dropped a cool $3,400 on her wack
book err I don't know if I announced
this but we were saying that we wanted
to find a competitor to the way yeah
we've talked about it but did I say that
razor reached out yeah so we were
talking about this
previously and razor followed me and DM
me and they're like yo I think I'll let
walk you up so razor sent us two of
these dirty dudes and what is this
called Dan it's called the razor razor
blade razor pain
vamp straight-up Vampire Slayer
they sent us two of these dirty dudes
and a bunch of gear and I was so stoked
because I actually do think after
researching it that this is the best
equivalent to the wack book that you can
find it's a it's a roughly the same
weight mm-hmm it's very slick and slim
here's the big differences I've only
been using it for a couple of days so
I'll check back in a little bit but I've
been using it we did some tests and
stuff so let me let me break this down
for you guys out there this laptop the
razor one costs beta approximately
$1,000 less this one's on sale for
$2,100 this one costs about 31:31 ah
yeah so here here here's where it got
real interesting we did one basic
function that I thought was super
important Dan put a like a 12-minute or
like a four minute clip into premiere
and loaded up a ton of effects on it and
we rendered them on both computers these
are both top-of-the-line and Dan what
was the do you remember how long it took
to do you have a written here yeah it's
in there yeah the the razor beat the Mac
by about what is it almost six minutes
yeah that it took the it took the razor
12 minutes to render this clip and and
the wack book 18 now that that to me is
one of the best benchmarks that you can
do in terms of editing computing gaming
rendering an effect heavy clip and the
razor I would say crushed on that test
it absolutely crushed and it's got adult
$1,000 less but there are other things
worth worth being considered here
the mousepad here is still unbeatable
the Mac Mouse is so [ __ ] up it is so
good like I can't get over them the Mac
mousepad when I started using it I was
totally obsessed we got this thing is
perfect
that's like the Bilbo Laurel up and down
its runs perfectly but the part that
gets you the most moist and bothers is
when you can click anywhere like on this
on this and other mouse pads you have to
lift your finger and then click on the
clinic does a sensor yeah but on the Mac
there's an actual click under the mouse
pad yes so the whole mouse pad is
clickable and it's big its massive now
here's the problem backlog being the not
the technologies that they are they
packed it in the mouse pad and the click
on the mouse pad so nobody else can do
it but that being said rate this this
one's probably the best I've seen the
that works really really good it works
is good just good so that I'm in love
with but it doesn't have to click and
it's smaller the screen is 4k this one
is not 4k yeah but it's small yours is a
touch screen yeah it's a touch screen I
can't decide how useful Advisor Mac has
the best speakers the speakers are
incredible but what I'm wondering and
like I'll keep using the computers like
the Mac does have a Polish but I'm just
wondering cuz $1,000 is a lot it's a lot
for raw computing power this is this is
the winner and no I well I'm gonna keep
using it I'm just saying it's been it's
been an interesting day already I didn't
know what to expect with that with that
render test yeah that was pretty pretty
bad for the what act what did you expect
when you ran that oh I I thought the Mac
will win I I expected the razor wind the
the main things would premiere cuz
Premiere gets accelerated by Nvidia
cards and they don't put in the video
cards in those Mac books anymore so are
you and are you indicating that if
you're using a different editing
software the results could be different
I mean
in final cut since it's Apple native I
mean you can't do a one-for-one
comparison though also Final Cut is
garbage
fight me fight me twitch jet no I don't
think no one really uses so anyway we're
gonna keep comparing but like it's it's
really interests me a thousand the thing
is like the Apple is really a status
symbol if you walk around with the Apple
girls want to [ __ ] you and guys want to
be you but with the razor in a way it's
like oh look at this gamer look at this
gamer carrying around his gaming left up
when you go in to play World of Warcraft
nerd like there is a there is a level of
that and I guess that's just in the
branding that that apples accomplished
but razors making a move here mmm-hmm
alright well we'll keep checking in on
that real interesting stuff this is all
idle curiosity it's not really an ad to
get YouTube this is not that I'm not
paid we're not paid by either of them
yeah this is just fueled by my hate of
Apple I might as heir to be like because
I went to ela got it I was like this is
the best laptop I've ever used how can
there not be another laptop out there
that's disco and doesn't cost thirty
four hundred dollars this one isn't
cheap either twenty one hundred bucks I
so far just from my personal experience
with it I have not been disappointed in
anything no the Mac is amazing so you
just open it and you use it that's it
updates yeah I don't know install drive
right and when I watch porn I don't even
get like worms that like steal my
identity
they just infect my lungs I love that
that was a selling point for a long time
about max you can't even get you can't
get viruses when you watch porn and and
rip [ __ ] was that huh because most
people use pcs so I guess virus
developers didn't bother to target Mac I
don't know if that's true anymore I feel
like that can't be true I feel like
bloatware and AD like viruses is kind of
a thing of the past
you have to be kind of a dumb-dumb to
get a virus on your computer these days
I guess because you haven't you have
AdBlocker Windows comes with a wonderful
virus protector yeah I mean if you're
going to like get money quick dot got
got them and you don't have ad block on
you're probably gonna get you're gonna
get got once the last time like if you
go to a porn site and you don't have ad
block on it's just like oh my god using
a block for so long by the way I have it
disabled for sites that I love okay
some sites you got to put it on because
you're just not insane it's like going
to a brothel and having sex well the
prostitutes without a condom it's like
it's just insane you have to wear
protection when it's necessary you know
so on YouTube I don't I don't I'm not
gonna get an STD on YouTube I don't I
don't there but if you go to like a
weird porn site to because there's like
reputable ones and then there's like
weird ones man that [ __ ] is a out of
this world but as people get older when
like our parents I think those are the
ones who are getting infected still yeah
when they go it's gonna be a weird new
world I don't want answering emails from
like hot singles in your area
yeah Nigerian Prince's I mean you get an
email your son is here with me and he
lost his wallet and you know that should
so crazy someone actually scammed my
grandma yeah I told you that story yeah
I was in college this was 10 years ago
somebody called my grandma she knew he
knew my name he knew enough about me my
birthday and everything and where I'm
from to convince her that he was me and
that he was in Mexico in a prison and
needed her descent to his bank three
thousand dollars to bail him out there's
so many questions like why are you
calling me you have parents you have
siblings you've it but he got her he got
her okay
we had a company event on Monday that
was probably one of the funnest days in
history we took the whole gang out the
Teddy fresh crew the h3h3 crew everyone
here and we went to Disneyland and we
did this thing called VIP tours and it
basically is like the golden ticket to
charli's factory it's the funnest it was
like the funnest day ever know what do
we have pictures of that there's
pictures on Instagram we were all
wearing red Teddy fresh beanies and we
can't recognize so much because well
it's hard to miss and also I was like
hey come say hi yeah but it was the
frickin faun his day so you basically
get to skip to the front of every line
and there's nothing more it's a it's a
feeling of both like oh I feel this is
like straight class warfare but also
there's something thrilling really it's
a really treat yourself yeah it's a
treat yourself there's something
thrilling about cutting in front of
little kids at Peter Pan's house waiting
for two hours the little kids rides with
horns I felt the guilty yeah like you
were right you straight-up walk in that
exit everyone's been waiting there
they've got their hand they're holding
him back for like an hour plus for this
shitty ride and we were walking straight
up the exit and I swear to God I didn't
do it but I felt like this is what was
happening I'd look at him and spit in
their face
and get on this little tiny little
children's ride and be like peace not
only that but you can also say you know
what I want to do this right again and
then you just you can ride a ride two
three times at Space Mountain spaceman
has the craziest line ever there was
eight of us we had like a whole coaster
and we're like we want to go again or
our tour guy was like you guys want to
go twice and it's like obviously yeah so
you first of all you cut in the line and
everybody because Space Mountain has got
like all these rows going up and a
rafter up so everyone's watching these
clowns with red beanies walk in the egg
that I oh you know what I don't figure
that people think it's like a VIP thing
where you just pay more people are
mentally yeah is that Disney if you're
in a wheelchair you get to go in the
exit they just thought you were disabled
they thought they thought I was [ __ ]
we all got the beanie so a group of
we're all make-a-wish I have seven cares
so I think it's more of a um the looks
are more of a mixture of curiosity and
help like [ __ ] those guys but when you
go on
and you come up you come out you had a
great time your eyes are watering from
laughing and screaming and cold air
blasting that's time right these guys
are waiting two hours
that's like again you get so fast right
that's the weird part
it was almost like a case study of like
how wealth and privilege how you can get
used to it so fast because the first two
are like exhilarating you're like this
is incredible this is so amazing this is
so much fun by the third one and towards
the end of the day it's just like I
remember we had to wait like two minutes
on guardians of galaxy and we were all
like what the [ __ ] is like is are you
serious like you're actually gonna make
me waiting on line with these plebeian
scumbags it's real interesting yeah how
you get used to it but I do think that
their suffering is part of the joy of
the experience of seeing everyone
waiting in line guardians of the galaxy
is so fun that was insane oh my god we
got on it and it's like you sit in a
room in front of like a screen so I kind
of thought it's one of those where
you're just sitting in art or what yeah
watching a movie would like effects and
stuff mm-hmm
completely not I've never been on a ride
like that it's a giant building and it
is like Star Tours in that you're
watching something and you're in a
little like row with people but the
actual row catapults up and down
incredible distances and oh my god is
crazy Lydia our product manager for
production manager for teddy fresh was
like yes screaming bloody murder man I
was I didn't
eel was clutching on for dear life that
was great that was fun that was a great
day pretty much lost my voice then next
day I was like I'm from yeah so tired
honestly and then if you guys are
boarding a plane to go ride to
Disneyland
bear this story of mine
Southwest passenger paid $8 for Wi-Fi to
Facebook live final moments during
emergency landing just kill your joy Oh
God
there was this story I don't think I've
heard this a Southwest flight the engine
just straight blew up midair and the
woman sitting next to the damn wing
which is me every flight how do I always
end up in the worst heat on airplanes
where it's like right over the wing and
so loudest most obnoxious place feel
like I'm that and that seat every time
well anyway so this woman the engine
blows up the window next to her shatters
is open to the elements and she sucked
out of that pitch sucked out halfway
people go and they pull her inside the
window and I really she died she died
from her injuries Wow
but she was almost halfway sucked out
they tried to resuscitate her I did the
thing about like airplane crashes always
trips me out whenever I'm on an airplane
I'm like this would be the worst time
ever for me to die because whenever
you're on an airplane you're either
you're doing something important you
wouldn't get on an airplane unless you
were doing something important either
going on vacation you're moving
somewhere you're going to see someone
that you haven't seen a long time it's a
life event when you get on it on an
airplane by by the nature of it for the
most part and I'm always like this is
the worst play time for me to die if
this plane goes it's the worst time for
everybody that's the scary part about
dying a plane crash as much as anything
it's like always the perfect and worst
time for you to die the most ironic
death possible I was ringing about this
couple they were flying this airplane
that disappeared from like it was going
to Thailand it was this really crazy one
in the Southeast Asia I don't remember
and just disappeared they didn't find it
like five hundred people perished and
there were writing stories about the
people on the plane and it was two
couples two old couples who were retired
and they were going on their first trip
outside the United States it was their
dream to go to Thailand and after all
their lives leading up to this minute
perishing on a [ __ ] airplane like wow
is just the most effed up way yeah man
it also reminds me of just what we just
watched last night with 60 minutes hmm
they're talking about this airline
company that like they just keep cutting
on their expenses by making their pilots
not do all the exams properly that was I
forgot what spirit no no no look up 60
minutes last night about of air was
their main story about this airline that
was basically their business model was
cutting safety they're the one of the
most probably agent all Allegiant yeah
Allegiant yeah their business model is
literally cutting safety regulations
yeah one of the most profitable ones and
everyone like in the in that field of
the you know Airlines and whatever
everyone apparently knows that and they
know not to fly them right that's great
yeah deregulate right but these guys
sort of deregulate everything is such
[ __ ] when you realize that there are
companies whose business model is to cut
safety features it was pretty scary
they had three to four times more midair
failures than other airlines anyway this
one we got sucked out of window that was
that was tragic but apparently the air
that the pilot landed this [ __ ] with
one engine working she landed it was a
female interesting at 170 miles per hour
she landed that [ __ ] airplane good
job that's crazy
pilots are crebbil I wonder how
underpaid and underappreciated pilots
are hmm do pilots make a lot of money
from fly for Airlines can you guys look
up the median salary for a like a
generally the one much rougher
commercial they they make good money I
know a guy who's a retired American
Airlines and he has a very comfortable
that's good I want them making money can
you tell me what's the median
Ellery can you look that up yeah we're
looking up that's good I want those guys
making my hundred K okay
105 ka that's the median so that's some
more some less God balsam yeah finally
someone's getting pay what they deserve
[ __ ] good friend of the show yeah boy
sky rally its Martin shkreli trading
fraud kobe increase the price of drugs
5,000 percent got him I don't mean to
take I don't mean to revel in his
misfortune he was denied he had
requested access to a minimum security
prison and the judge to straight-up
denied him and at this point I I saw
that I was like wow this is just revenge
at this point I kind of feel bad for the
guy in that because he's not a threat
like other prisoners were they afraid of
Martin shkreli
is he gonna troll control his way out of
prison
he might he murder
he's like the Joker he's like yeah some
advocare on bait relative to uh send the
prison into ma'am um I'm starting to
feel bad for this guy for Christ's sake
going to prison for such a long time man
just made a couple memes either close
the cell lock him up throw away the keys
boys guys let's take a quick commercial
break
it's this one's gonna be quick and dirty
so don't go away we have a literally a
10-pound joint that we're all gonna
smoke when we come back to celebrate
this 4/20
it's literally the sizes of this table
so please don't go away appreciate you
and I love you let's get so it stay
tuned
do not leave please I need you Dan cut
me off
thank you too for hymns for sponsoring
this episode of the H Street podcast did
you guys know that 66% of men lose their
hair by age 35 that's kind of insane
although in Israel yeah everybody's bald
as well it's kind of insane I hear I'm
surprised
yeah people have big beautiful heads of
hair but I guess it maybe starts
receding by that time thing is when you
notice that your hair is leaving your
head it's already too late it's much
easier to keep the hair you have than to
replace the hair you've lost is that
hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet that feels
mean they made me read that they're like
did you everybody sees its bald I don't
know but I heard sleek they can receding
hairline less distinguished I've said
this previously Bruce Willis he's a
superstar you just have a hair on his
head I agree and I want to tell everyone
who's kind of balding it's not that bad
like I know we're we're waiting here a
solution for you but I also don't want
you to feel bad but what's the other
option
what are you gonna get hair plugs that's
expensive who can afford that Steve
Steve Carell I wonder how much that cost
you guys notice how Steve Carell between
like season 1 and season 2 season 1 he's
receding like crazy and season - he's
like found that Fountain of Youth he
aged backwards it's like magic the one
that he's got really good but like when
you see people on the street like
they're just they're some that are
really mad or I mean hey if you if you
don't believe in in trying for hims you
could just tattoo a hair on your bald
ass head like fouseytube did okay and
that poor guy man that was a rough
decision that wasn't a good decision for
him don't tattoo anything on your head
and unless you have $50,000 you're not
getting hair plugs let's focus for names
com a one-stop shop for skin care and
hair loss solutions for men thanks to
science baldness can be optional that's
that's a beautiful thing Thank You
science Ames connects you with real
doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss well known generic
equivalents to name-brand prescriptions
to help keep your hair no gas station
counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science answer a few
questions a doctor will review and
prescribe products are shipped directly
to your door that's pretty special I
mean hey if
you you know if you're if you're worried
about your hair falling out give it a
shot why not for Christ's sake
you know I know a lot of guys are
insecure about it and I can only imagine
the horror that that that horrible
moment when you are shampooing your hair
and it's just like what is that pain is
how many know my hair was really long
like when I was young I had like really
long hair and I don't know if for some
reason but I was shedding hair much more
when it was long and I remember when I
was showering once in shampooing I was I
came out from doing my hair and there
was tons of hair my hands and I started
freaking out when I cut my hair it
stopped happening that happens to me but
I can so I can imagine how you feel
water now our listeners get a free trial
sorry our listeners get a trial month of
hymns for just $5 pretty much free right
now while supplies last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds of dollars if you went to
a doctor or pharmacy so go to for hymns
calm HD that's fo r hims calm /h 3 4
amps calm /h 3 2 get started for just 5
bucks today give it a shot why not
thanks for hymns and we've got C geek
everybody's favorite place to get
tickets mine certainly thanks to seat
geek for sponsoring this video if you
don't know C kick is a ticket app for
live events NBA concerts post melona
whatever you want they've got it
I personally love using this site
because it first of all it's easy to use
and they have these wonderful things
that I've not seen anywhere else for one
you can see a view of this seat where
you're sitting so say you're getting a
Dodger ticket or whatever so you can
actually see a view from the seat you
know exactly what to expect and they put
a score of 1 to 10 Green is good red is
bad to let you know what kind of deal
you're getting because they have retail
and they also have resale on the site so
maybe you want to go to an event that
was sold out and someone's reselling you
can see how good or bad of a deal you're
getting based on the history of the
price of that ticket
give you all this wonderful information
you can't get it anywhere else as far as
I'm aware I haven't seen it I love them
they're good company they they're great
we got a hook up here this is
unbelievable if you use code h3h3 you
get $20 off your first order just click
the me tab on the app and enter code
h3h3 for 20 bucks off that's damn just
eating the cost there just straight up
giving you 20 bucks to go to your
favorite show
that's incredible deal click the link in
the description to download the app use
code h3 HD for $20 off your first
SeatGeek order I highly recommend them
I'm a big fan of them and thank you so
much seeking for sponsoring the show
with that being said let's go welcome
back everybody did you all hear about
the Wells Fargo's some deep doo-doo
deep deep doo-doo my friends they're
being charged a billion dollars from
some government agencies because they
defrauded people they were learning
mortgages and car auto loans too they
were overcharging people knowingly and
what happens as a result they get
charged a billion dollars Wow so the
bill of the billion when I heard that I
was like great do the people they scam
get their money back so it turns out
they've they're gonna repay 128 million
to the auto scams they haven't decided
yet what they're gonna do about the
mortgage scams but it's like here here's
the problem with these evil scumbags
these CEOs that run these banks to just
[ __ ] pillage the whole world the
government for whatever reason has
chosen that not to prosecute these
criminals these absolute human parasites
there's proof that they did that
knowingly knowingly Wow
and so since especially the big collapse
with all the loan ding the mortgage
thing [ __ ] that caused all the collapse
of the economy in 2008 it was nobody got
punished and so now it's just become
it's just become part of the equation of
their business plan they says
we can overcharge every person a
thousand bucks and maybe we'll get
caught and we'll have to pay the
government a billion dollars but we're
gonna make five billion we're gonna make
five billion dollars and you know what's
[ __ ] up the government makes money
from it they've made pac people but
guess guess what they're gonna keep half
a billion dollars for themselves so it's
almost like they're in this racket
together we're gonna scam all these
people and then the government comes
around is like I got a wet my beak
that's insane and Wells Fargo recently
they had more drama with them opening
bank accounts people yep they're opening
savings accounts and checking accounts
without asking anyone and then they
would accrue penalties isn't that
beautiful
there's another layer to this too you
know I think as over twenty thousand
cars got repo'd because of the
overcharges what do it so that's
irreparable damage to people's lives
yeah the [ __ ] your credit and it's all
[ __ ] your job I mean you lose your car
you you what that's rock bottom that
[ __ ] up your life in a lot of ways
these people are so [ __ ] evil and
what happens is these evil [ __ ]
when they retire or they get fired for
the scam but they they pocketed like 100
million dollars they get to go get a job
in Washington regulating all their
friends that's what it seems like
because our government is run by such
[ __ ] cowards and by the way Donald
Trump mr. drained the swamp what
happened mm-hmm what swamp is being
drained who was going to prison for
stealing a billion [ __ ] dollars from
hardworking Americans why are these
people not going to prison for life
when one black guy concealed a mars bar
and go to prison for ten years
yeah or just sit at Starbucks they
weren't actually sent to prison but
every American wants to see these
soulless evil [ __ ] put in prison so
where's the justice
there's not one American you say hey
this white collar banker stole a billion
dollars should we go to prison every
no person is going to say yes but
somehow all the regulators and even the
president he has the authority he could
say lock that [ __ ]
up why is the swamp not draining it
makes me so angry and now they're
talking about rolling back the
regulations of all they put in place of
2008 really put on all these regulations
on banks to make sure you couldn't have
all this [ __ ] scams again yeah and
they're taking them away they're
removing them now
those [ __ ] oh my god they're so evil
how much money do you need to make why
do you need to scam people for an extra
billion your bank is already worth
trillions of dollars why I don't
understand that level of greed like
wealth is useful to an extent if you
have a billion dollars what what is an
additional dollar worth you what does an
additional billion dollars worth to you
I don't understand that greed what
drives you you psychopath I really don't
know it's like this home all these
companies like this airline that will
just save money by putting older
everyone in danger you know not doing
all the checkups they're supposed to do
just to save money you know what it is
like how do you sleep at night they find
really beautiful creative ways to just
fight you know what it is a normal
person like where were were rich by by
comparison to someone who's making
$30,000 a year but like real rich we're
still normal people because real rich is
like billionaires billionaires spend
money on a level that we cannot fathom
they can sway the result of elections
they can throw 50 million dollars at an
election and actually influence it yeah
so in that sense having that much money
is is unbelievable power when you can
just throw away fifty million dollars
and run an ad on every single television
set in the whole country but it's like I
man these people are playing with fire
dude I swear to God
sickos man that's crazy
I just don't know why it's seriously so
depressing to me it makes me lose faith
in this country that none of these
bankers have gone to prison not one of
these spineless cowards
thanks peanuts I feel like if this was
another country someone would go well
there was I meant there was similar
scandals going on in Europe and and and
other places in North America and they
went they went to prison but our guys
got off clean you don't even know the
names they're the greatest thief's of
all time you don't even know their names
it really it's upsetting like the
greatest villains ever and as long as
you pay the government a couple hundred
million you're good to go and do it
again [ __ ] man yeah let's watch a fine
video this guy cracks me up this is a
classic but I have not seen it since
recently so mate but it gave me a
[ __ ] big away it's 4/20 right now
it's 4/20 on 4/20
[Applause]
4/20 was gonna be stuck in that this guy
absolutely cracked this guy just said
black hole and a perfectly like he's
saying like the state funding is being
sucked up like a black hole and this guy
goes excuse me excuse me
[Laughter]
can you imagine actually asking for an
apology yeah serious there's a follow-up
clip that I want to play by can I get an
apology watch his reaction he's just
speechless
oh great so I was like well what the
hell was that and then I saw there was a
follow-up video somebody interviewed him
later on about this issue and he doubled
he double downs man he hold the black
hole big time quiet you got more volume
you can do this
you got more of I pranked it I'm crank
to where is the volume can I get a
volume why is it so damn quiet your
crank time cranked cranked and fully
cranked right now she's my mouse there
it is
are you cranked bro we're all cranked
cranking all day we can boost it in post
right give a lot yeah we'll have to yeah
it's a real low right now you're super
loud that's what the guy says in a real
I love that his he somehow just like
black in any context this is great
and look that he has had time to reflect
on it and he's doubling down on it
that's like me getting upset that
somebody's like says jewelry
excuse me jewelry what is that because
I'm greedy because I'm Jewish that like
jewelry jewelry why'd you harp Jew harp
well that's yeah that's just insane I
can't believe it an instrument called a
Jew heart that's not ironic mm-hmm have
you guys heard of this movie out right
now
Jumanji I'm sorry the raw Kevin Hart are
you serious this is in theaters right
now Jumanji unbelievable I demand an
apology from the president
Wikipedia you know turn in the you know
astrological scientific term but I mean
there's so the next thing you'll be
telling me is that you know Black Friday
you know he keeps his obsessive Black
Friday but Black Friday is great Black
Friday is great everybody loves Black
Friday
everyone knows black not like
astrological but you're the one that
uses an example every once in a while
something with black will be good you're
the one that brought it up you dip why
does that mean a black hole is a word
singing a noun black holes are known
black gold the last top blackboard
writing on the blackboard and sometimes
it's the context in which things are
used it's the user it's to use it right
I mean you say now to change name to
white money well they changed white
money or do do something with fried
white christmas' dreaming of a white
Christmas and skies grits indicating in
terms of the society oh well no we talk
about I love this I love this philosophy
like I reserve the right to be offended
anytime someone says black no matter
what the context is that's like a
superpower man super social justice
I remain I retain the power any time
someone at utters the word Jew within a
word or were itself the next time you
see Jumanji
expect my face to pop up and be doing
this how dare you support this criminal
institution don't you remember the
Holocaust and now you're here watching
Jumanji that's a science term yeah this
was a story that gotten the might this
story rattled my DAGs in New Zealand
they say when they want you to hurry up
they say rattle your DAGs they call
dingleberries the sheep have dried poop
this form around their [ __ ] they call
them DAGs so and they want you to hurry
up they say rattle your DAGs is that
great I love that youtuber faces jail
for video forcing homeless men to eat
toothpaste this guy sounds like a real
piece of [ __ ] let's read this article
barcelona-based youtuber faces up to two
years in prison over video in which he
fed Oreos filled with toothpaste to a
homeless man and joke they would give
him long overdue clean King Cotton King
guac in that was racist for me
known as resset to his more than a
million subscribers film himself giving
filling the biscuits with toothpaste and
replacing them in their back and their
packing before feeding five of them to a
homeless man he ate five without
noticing there was toothpaste in it yeah
that's he was hungry or maybe he was on
drugs he was drunk
this is a good flavor of toothpaste
maybe maybe it was dank maybe it was
good maybe he's like I don't remember
Oreos tasting this way but this is good
as the 52 year old man ate the cookies
resset jibed maybe I've gone a bit far
but look at the positive side this will
help him clean his teeth I think he
hasn't had them clean since he became
poor I love that that association of
just like you're broke now somehow I
don't know this that whatever resset 20
year old originally from China earned
more than 2000 euros from YouTube for
advertising link to the video which was
viewed at thousands of times doesn't
sound like a lot thousands of times
according to court documents reported by
Spanish
daily he now faces a charge of a crime
against moral integrity I was like whoa
that's a crime in Spain crime against
moral integrity this thing was I mean
it's pretty pretty wild law with Spanish
prosecutors seeking a sentence of two
years in prison in order to pay thirty
thousand euro to the homeless guy that's
sick for the homeless guy the homeless
dude was originally from Romaric Romania
said he was ill after eating the
toothpaste filled biscuits I got sick
after five minutes and threw up he
related explaining that he had not known
who rested was and came to fear for his
life it goes on it gets even weirder
after the video drew immediate outrage
resset returned to see his victim the
following day and made of another film
asking him how the biskits had gone down
he said people exaggerate over jokes in
the street played on beggar's when
surely if it's done to a normal person
they wouldn't say anything I don't
understand that statement I mean yeah
mate I mean first of all that's not true
but you're preying on the defenseless
and that's what makes it so [ __ ] up
mm-hmm
that's like going and kicking a puppy
it's like he's a defenseless old
homeless guy he's vulnerable
yeah the youtuber said that and his
follow-up video to defend himself
[ __ ] psycho
as a contravariant in you to grow ressa
and a friend again visited him with a
camera with the intention of spending
the night with him at which point a
witness called the police so these guys
were actually being so disturbing with
this guy they were gonna spend the whole
night that a passerby er called the
police so I mean there yeah it sounds
like they're just harassing the guy at
this point desperate to like make
himself not look like a psycho
prosecutors said that wrested had later
deleted the video and offered the
homeless man 300 euro for his silence in
an attempt to reestablish his image and
integrate himself with public opinion in
great ingratiate rested who is currently
on bail awaiting judgment previously
offered sandwiches filled with his cat's
excrement to children and elderly people
the court heard that part really got me
hard 9 that's so much worse yeah
yeah this got the homeless guy said he
had never been treated so badly on the
street adding that the bar where he
vomited after the incident regularly
helped him with food and clothing guys
[ __ ] hell this is this is like the
real dark side of YouTube is like that
room is really green what is going on
that room is so green what the hell
it's just like actually giving little
Psychopaths with no moral well it looks
like a kid yeah he looks really young
but like I mean three times is a charm
man yeah I feel like if I do that a
young age I would do it without thinking
and thinking it was funny and then I
would feel really bad afterwards like
wow that was psycho I used to do [ __ ] as
that like as a kid be like and then in
retrospect that was psycho of me yeah
but to do it three times but it's crazy
today cuz you can have a youtube channel
yeah it makes it way worse because
they're doing it for the attention of
potentially millions of people and being
paid for it that's kind of the trouble
YouTube's in right now how do we curate
how do we not pay these [ __ ] alright
it's tough it's a tough job anyway [ __ ]
that guy god bless him though
pushing best don't [ __ ] with homeless
people yeah I never got that it's so
lame and the like I don't know all this
it's like it's such a phenomenon on
YouTube and it never ends like here we
go now a kids and still making videos
about homeless people I thought we were
done way down yeah yeah those were the
days man back in like 2015 there's like
this homeless phenomenon where every
prankster they're just like free extras
right right or or free stars they are
like the star of it yeah like a whole
cinderella story yeah we're at the end
they're back on the street and he made a
bunch of money
best cinder Loureiro story ever where
the fairy godmothers get paid at seven
or Ella's back in the basement uh man I
got more videos to show you guys
who wants to watch more video save me
thank you
I can't hear you guys at home if you did
say me here's a clip of what the [ __ ] is
mail-order bride goes in for the kiss at
their wedding
okay seen this one here's what I don't
get about a guy who's willing to do a
mail-order bride like here I don't think
you even need volume for this your your
only look at that make you better and
just enjoy this the vision of this
Ronald Reagan oh well you just vomited
she looks like she's pushing 50 but
she's dressed like she's 16 maybe 18 I
shouldn't okay so as a guy who's willing
to order a bride from Russia you
understand that you cannot find a woman
in America and that a Russian girl is
coming for the explicit reason that
you're American and that by marrying you
she can get a green card so I don't know
what kind of men like that it's just
weird to acknowledge that and go for it
yeah that's the last option for these
people and I think they also rationalize
it in different ways like I remember
seeing some documentaries about this
stuff and they're just like I don't know
that they are helping them in a way to
get out of a situation like the lady is
probably in a bad place what she doesn't
want to be he's saving her they say yeah
it's like but still just so he thinks
that they'll they'll gonna like a preet
like you're my Savior yeah it's weird
man I would I would be interested to
find if any fruitful relation lasting
relationship ever happened as a result
of their like well here's the beginning
of one
turn that up
yep
yeah this guy's names
he looks why does it look like he's on
his lunch break right now Melton from
the office base he's definitely from
office base yeah what would you say you
do around here
damn she's a champ she's a champ she
wants that green card real bad so I
don't I don't know it's all interesting
thing I said I can't really make fun of
these guys there it's desperation like
oh lucky me I got a wife you know like
if you sometimes I don't know love you
can find it in many forms I mean if when
it's explicitly a mail-order bride
so do they they really get a green card
like so no follow-up or checkup that
this isn't legit if they really are
married I'm living together right there
there there are certain checkpoints in
immigration but it's possible they have
to come with the intention of like we're
dating
and I'm coming to be with them so she
enters on a visa and then and then if
they get married during that time there
is roads to getting a green card
although you have to you have to avoid
as much possible showing that the
intention was to come to get a green
card because that is illegal but I guess
it's hard to I don't know it's so
complicated I don't really know me and
ela we were trapped in Israel for so
long because we wanted to move to the US
but we just read that it was so much
safer and smarter to do it in Israel so
immigration knew that our intentions
were pure mm-hmm to apply for a garden
in Israel because if we move to America
and then got married and then applied
from America it looks it looks more
shady and I think at that point I may
have had to like stay here for a few
years without living I was one of their
fears but I know a lot of people who
that happen to and they don't have a
problem so I don't know Stephanie a hard
procedure and to get the green card yeah
it's brutal it is brutal
um let's see what else
dude you guys sprayed this [ __ ] this
kind of shocked me I'm gonna read this
article
about fulfillment fulfillment centers
having slave-like conditions where
workers are are pushed to be so
productive that they're peeing in
bottles because they're actually afraid
to take a bathroom break this is an
America that sounds like like conditions
and sweatshops and China did it the more
I learn about chip it's a really big
price thing to hear that about Amazon
well what it says in the in the article
is that it's not just Amazon 75% of
fulfillment centers yeah it's just the
way they run these things although
Amazon should know better they shouldn't
but I thought Amazon created this
atmosphere where everything has to be
delivered tomorrow yeah they did but
also Jeff Bezos is worth nearly a
trillion dollars so hire a couple more
people so tape that's what I mean about
the psychopath like the richest man in
the world right he's the richest man in
the world it's like so pay an extra ten
million dollars a year and hire more
people so people can go the bathroom
that doesn't even come close to
affecting your bottom line when you
personally are worth a trillion [ __ ]
dollars yeah they give an example of the
workers for example will be working at
the top floor in like a four-story
building and to have to go to the
bathroom they have to go all the way
down right so obviously they would take
them forever and the gate they get paid
by sending a certain amount of packages
an hour like that they give them you
know target goals that they have to do
and they also they recently kept raising
it too so it's like doubled from where I
was when they started get paid by their
productivity so yeah they have to well
it's like if you don't then you get you
get a strike yeah and apparently also
women for getting sick or whatever
bring a doctor's note I don't know they
can't make it to work they would get a
strike for that it's like did we need
unions we need unions people who think
we don't need regulations that we can
trust the the the market to regulate
itself bro it's not happening it's not
happening unless you're a billionaire
that doesn't benefit you
if you know anyone who's working class
they're getting [ __ ] slam dunked on
by some psychopath billionaire so
they're peeing in bottles by the way the
more I learn about like stuff the more I
suspect I just I'm so skeptical I we
work with China on Teddy fresh so I
started to learn more about what's going
on there they get and then there's
there's other stuff to this okay that's
not that simple but they get in China a
month off the whole [ __ ] country
takes a whole month off everything shuts
down you cannot work with these Chinese
factors for an entire month and the
whole country is on vacation meanwhile
in America there's this canoe always
here like oh man sweatshops in China
they're all getting worked out to the
[ __ ] teeth meanwhile they've got a
whole month off and we're pissing in
bottles to just remain productive
there's no mandated vacation days
there's no mandated sick days there's no
there's like 12 days of pregnancy
guaranteed can you imagine having a baby
and coming back to work 12 days later
that's what a lot of companies expect
that always blows my mind Israel you get
you get a minimum of three months first
of all and then you can you can up you
can choose to like what you call it
postpone it or right make it longer up
to nine months and you still have your
job
my sister is only now going back to work
after nine months so and Israel is kind
of like the first three months are part
of like second world like like is yeah
the first 3 months are paid and you can
keep your job and take another
additional six months and Europe it's
even it's even crazier and I just it's
this American attitude is it's a
sickness of like we're all just
temporary embarrassed millionaires you
know this sickness that's like I got
mine and [ __ ] everyone else it's so
[ __ ] up in China has better working
conditions you guys I'm sure like I'm
not you know the sweatshops and the
horrible stuff you do hear about China
I'm sure exists they're not saying that
it does
yeah but like you don't you don't hear
that they get a month off right imagine
Americans don't know that if Americans
knew that Iran was getting a month off
you think they would be [ __ ] happy
about that these guys running up and
down peeing in bottles getting paid like
what $15 an hour it's crazy
oh and and I was learning about Tesla
their factory they do this you know well
Tesla factory has an awful reputation of
just really really they do [ __ ] where
they they shut down the factory for a
week or two weeks to modify the the
assembly line and they force everybody
to take either they force them to take
their paid vacations or they don't pay
them so it's like yeah and it's it's
like you are responsible for them they
work for you full time I understand that
you're under financial strain but you
hire someone full-time you're
responsible for their well-being you
can't just cut someone's mana this money
off for two two weeks so they think that
happens all the time they have to close
their they have to close the factory
factor anyway so they're like they say
you can't you yeah you if you have to
take vacation days or you don't get paid
and they probably have like what if
you've worked there for a while I mean
God knows how much they give there
you're not required by law to give any
do you think it's a boy using people at
Walmart and Kmart and all these [ __ ]
shitty jobs have vacation days they
don't have any I was talking to someone
recently it was our movers we moved
recently and the mover works full time
for this moving company he says he gets
no vacation days no one he works his ass
off every day and he can't miss a day
cuz obviously he's got bill sees a
family and [ __ ] and it's not a high
paying job he has no vacation days I
don't understand it how like how is it
that in Israel people have better like I
don't know in Israel everyone feels like
you're being [ __ ] over by everyone
right but it's not I guess you have at
least the minimum I think is 12 vacation
days yes
twelve is the starting point but then
there's the maternity leave and there's
a you get health care I don't know
there's a lot and stuff the health care
there is affordable everyone got it yeah
I think a problem is that there's so
many people in America like Israel is
like five million Israelis and greater
is in like non-palestinian Israel same
with with like Europe you have 300 over
300 million people in America I don't
know there's something about it's just
how America is so driven by money yeah
everything is so like you said all the
billionaires they affect everything by
dropping like fifty million on something
mm-hmm and they lobby Congress to
prevent laws like in unions in the [ __ ]
it's depressing man America has the
potential to actually be the greatest
country that ever [ __ ] existed man
there's so much potential like honest to
god people people people would take what
I'm saying
some people would and say like your aunt
you hate America or something like that
which is insane I think people like
Bernie Sanders and socialists and people
like that who more appreciate models
like in Sweden and Norway in Scandinavia
call them unamerican socialism's on
American why I don't know it's it's
crazy they're liars about it they say oh
the Nazis were socialists okay all right
well enjoy the non sick days that you
get and no maternity no um let me read
this article actually I meant to read
this it's real interesting title Amazon
warehouse workers allegedly paying
bottles to avoid punishment while Amazon
is known for revolutionary ecommerce
with its quick delivery system for a
variety of products its workers
allegedly sacrificed eyelet time to meet
the company's demands workers in the UK
oh this is in the UK so what the [ __ ]
did I just talk about
this particular order of goal is about a
UK one we're looking at another one that
was talking about in Arizona it might
even be the same article that just
further down they're saying that um that
there that's [ __ ] interesting that's
going on - UK jail
it's just Amazon man they say places in
Europe - they Amazon warehouses they're
just kind of hell holes since you
brought this up a lot of people have
been in the Twitter chat saying that oh
yeah whatever for Amazon and stuff
really it was the worst job they ever
had really yeah yeah do you know that
under that beautiful facade of like
Amazon Amazon we loved it
underneath that beautiful sod is just
like human pain and suffering let's be
sure to remind our viewers that they can
subscribe for free with Amazon - a tribe
thank you Jeff Bezos um God keep me out
of the warehouse guys let's slammed that
subscribe button for free yeah I don't
know what what's going on Jeff seems
like a decent guy so I don't know why
you wouldn't care more about having good
good um conditions anyway God will work
him out yesterday I've got it loaded up
on my ps4 and I gotta tell you it's what
I want to be doing right now we're going
tomorrow - Jax Jax films is getting
married tomorrow yeah I'm super excited
it's gonna be fun we went shopping we
got some nice clothes we hate it and
we're in it we're gonna wake up early
and go shopping I hate shopping for
dresses I hate it you look good
get that white down okay really mm-hmm
yeah we were joking that I should roll
up in my Gucci tracksuit and a little
white gown so that will suck up all the
attention of the whole wedding nobody
will notice Jack and Erin suck it up
like a black hole Oh
I'm sorry can i okay dan we're gonna
need a public apology so sorry anyway
that's about it for this week that's it
remember guys ninja is on Monday it's
gonna be great
sorry I shouldn't have done that out of
all I did that I'm reading right now
that so many things SpaceX [ __ ] over
engineers and it's one of the worst
places to work I don't die as an
engineer what's the [ __ ] because he let
the great pyramids do you know how the
great pyramids were built we marvel at
them we think they're beautiful
wonderful things today straight-up human
slavery and death and today when we
build big beautiful things we get we
have to get as close to human slavery
and death as legally possible that's how
you build great things slavery and death
I don't like that what we're getting
better if you want to look at it like
comparatively like it's getting better
and hopefully in another 50 years it
will be even better you know in another
50 years it's going to be robot zipping
around building pyramids and we're gonna
be lounge and we'll all have our own
robot sex robots and our VR goggles it's
gonna be a-okay is everyone smoking weed
right now and all right that's it thank
you guys hope you had fun oh thank you
so much for watching it hey where can
people ask questions for a ninja next
Monday the subreddit oh what's up did I
not say that I don't think you sorry
guys that's only gonna let me check make
sure it's up there it's up there you
[ __ ] [ __ ] see people were
studying but everything in the question
cell okay fYI didn't exist what game
would you be streaming how did you find
fortnight is Drake your favorite rapper
why did you say the n-word
got it what what did he say the black
would he say black hole by the way I saw
that ninja n-word controversy it was the
dumbest [ __ ] I ever I want I washed it
like five times and I couldn't even
legibly hear him saying I don't even
know the story yet well anyway it's
completely blown over doesn't matter it
happened a while ago that about does it
y'all
yeah buddy deputy what's the porky pigs
I know that'll better better that's all
folks
I don't know crushed it give it a minute
ever did I did it ma'am I believe it's a
baddy baddy baddy ever D ever DM yeah
yeah that sounds right happy happy ever
D I would be a that's all folks how
hyped for beer bongs and Bentley's I'm
just reading from the chat I'm super
super super hyper I heard his one single
stay they did during the Bud Light thing
and it was like so good sounded amazing
and soon awake right yeah it's coming up
I'm gonna hype it for sure alright y'all
you know what's funny we made the video
where we were backstage with posts
Malone and his [ __ ] record label
claimed the video I was like you and I
told Austin I don't and like i disputed
it and I told him and then they came
back again what the hoods but play and
then they got me to the point where I
would either have to get a strike right
you basically challenged him to a game
of chicken really strike me I dare you
or they can release played that and I
was like you know what [ __ ] this
I hate these companies that try to
muscle they're like I don't care who it
is it's funny because Austin clearly
wouldn't want that obviously I mean I
went there and I we promoted him it's
like the opposite of copyright
infringement yeah well I wrote in the
because you have all these options to
say why you're disputing it and I said I
was literally
with no artist you know I have the
artist permission yeah watch the video
idiot and then they they let it go after
that thank God I thought it's funny
though even I got a I got a compliment
you by the way
on you're slouching this is like left
the frame it's the end of the show man
my mom give me a [ __ ] break it's
Friday my dudes it's funny can you see
my head stuff yeah you're a little in
you started the top of frame and we've
we've almost lost you
[Music]
I'm not going anywhere
[ __ ] all you you would think I'm going
somewhere everyone knows that I'm
staying smashed like I won who know who
everyone who's real one who was right or
dying knows that I'm not going anywhere
smash subscribe and keep me out of the
fight anyone who wants to lock even in
this position right now click a like
with a little axe yeah what smash like
to lock in your answer ok what else I've
ever played got a war but I'm looking
forward to playing the new one I heard
like it's insane you didn't play the the
old school ones mm-hmm they're good yeah
this one is supposed to be like out of
the salon stirpes yeah Master P silicon
masterpiece I've been trying to I've
been trying to die I mean bread or I've
been on the keto the keto diet cracker
you don't I don't stand the keto diet
they're like ok for breakfast eat eggs
and cheese and bacon deep fried and
coconut oil but whatever you do don't
eat an apple don't eat fruit
I'm like bro that does not it say ok if
you want to believe that good luck with
your diet like there's some simple
basics I refuse to believe that that
Apple is not healthy for me than bacon
and cheese and eggs deep fried and
coconut oil maybe I'm wrong it's like I
understand the logic of the bay
six of it but then to add bacon and to
remove an apple don't need an apple
whatever the [ __ ] you do because you'll
get out of your KitKat a toaster state
Alex said that to me crack me up
doses it's like a it's like a heightened
state apparently when you are really
strictly following Kato you go into
ketosis which is a heightened state of
awareness there's a lot of comments here
I lost almost a hundred pounds on keto
before it was cool it makes sense as a
weight loss by the way yeah I agree I
mean I've been trying to lose weight
[Laughter]
I've been it's been actually good for me
because I I really can get down with
like steaks and fat and eggs and all
that but bread is hard but I'm doing
okay mostly I think just not eating
processed food and trips and stuff has
made a big difference it's just when I
heard that don't eat fruit that I I took
it personally because I love fruits dad
come grab the camera
[Music]
[Laughter]
but like this whole thing I'm like don't
eat fruit just seems fishy to me I see
someone who said you can still eat some
berries I think I don't like that no
usually definitely eat a lot of berries
I don't like your hesitation about some
berries you can have three berries you
can have 10 slices of bacon 20 pieces of
cheese and a New York Strip why'd you
say I can't hear you but you can have
three only three berries that you go out
of ketosis
what were you indicating right now down
this way
this guy's talking about there is a
thing with people who have left SpaceX
for Virgin Airlines that's a thing like
I left my ex for a virgin cutie she's so
hot she only eats three berries a day
she's Steven a catatonic state
all right let's end this hope you guys
had fun we'll see you on Monday with
ninja right everyone out there freud's
don't forget to blaze and play God war
this weekend and wish jacksFilms and
Erin a happy wedding and a beautiful
life are the two young lovebirds
all right just kill it for Christ's sake